هؤلاء يغنون لقطعه من الجبن لكنهم ليسوا
بمجانين فهناك دراسه اثبتت ان الاجبان
عندما تستمع الى الموسيقى يتحسن طعمها
ويحلو مذاقها
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
يقال ان الموسيقى غذاء للروح لكن هناك
دراسه وسويسريه لفتت الانظار الى علاقه
غريبه جماعه الجبنه والموسيقى
فبحسب العلماء القائمين على الدراسه من حق
الاجبان ايضا ان تستمتع بالموسيقى كما
البشر وانت تاثر بها ايضا
فالاجبال المدلله تذوقت طعم الموسيقى قبل
ان يتذوق البشر طعمها وضعت هذه الاجبان في
صناديق خشبيه كل واحده بمفردها هذه القطعه
مثلا استمعت اثناء نضجها لموسيقى الهيب
هوب هذه انستطلي موسيقى كلاسيكيه واخرى
لذذت بالموسيقى الروك وكانت النتيجه
اختلافات واضحه للغايه في الملمسي والمذاق
والشكل
[موسيقى]
اللغه العربيه
مين هبل
تها يمكن بالفعل ان تؤثر على التفاعلات
الكيميائيه في البكتيريا داخل الجبن ويبدو
ان لجنه التحكيم اجمعت على نجاح التجربه
جروب
يبقى
ربنا في المستقبل ليس علينا ان نسال فقط
عن اسعار الجبن ومصدر الالبان التي صنعت
منها بل سنتم ايضا بنوع الموسيقى التي
نضجت هذه الاجبان على الحانها شاركونا
ارائكم ما هي الموسيقى التي ترغبون في
تناول الجبن على الحانها